bonsoir à troyes demain toute la ville
participera aux obsèques de philippe
bertrand qui se dérouleront à l'église
saint bruno et chacun témoignera ainsi
aux parents de philippe sa compréhension
et partagera à leur peine quant à
patrick henry pour l'instant il n'a rien
avoué ce qui laisse plusieurs points
dans l'ombre
le juge d'instruction a été déchargé de
tous ses autres dossiers pour s'occuper
de celui ci conformément à la procédure
d'urgence demandée par monsieur lecanu
mais le garde des sceaux a tenu à
préciser que procédure d'urgence ne
voulait pas dire justice expéditive
il insistait sur le fait que la justice
doit conserver sa sérénité
les premiers résultats de l'autopsié
situe la mort du petit garçon à 15 jours
la date précise est un point capital de
l'enquète philippe at il été tué dès le
lendemain du rapt ou bien il y avait il
eu préméditation dans le premier cas son
acte se situerait après la communication
téléphonique du ravissant avec le grand
père de la victime
et s'il en était ainsi la fausse
manoeuvre de la gendarmerie serait
regrettable si philippe à ce moment là
était encore en vie l'arrestation de
patrick henry ne s'ouvraient pour les
gendarmes il n'y a pas eu de mauvaise
coordination entre la police et la
gendarmerie responsables étaient réunis
au commissariat de police de troyes il y
avait parmi eux dans le groupement de
gendarmerie a abandonné il ya eu lieu un
flottement en a craint que les policiers
en civil n'arrive pas à temps pour
surveiller si les individus et le
groupement de gendarmerie a fait sombre
du service il a dit je peux envoyer la
brigade de bréviandes qui est tout
proche
ainsi si vous le souhaitez le il a eu
l'accord 1 du commissaire central et des
autres responsables de l'opération qui
se trouvaient là
il a immédiatement donné ordre par radio
d'aller appréhendé l'individu qui
téléphonent à cet endroit il se trouvait
qu'un véhicule de la gendarmerie
stationnées à quelques centaines de
mètres de cette cabine téléphonique
les gens ils sont allés immédiatement le
plus vite possible mais sans gyrophare
et sans sirène et ont malheureusement
l'individu les a vus arriver de loin et
a pris la fuite